This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。保证真人。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披铠甲。它向世界传递出一个信号：你不是好惹的。这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须去这样做，请听并学习。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,|||通过 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《以艰难的方式学习》。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗挫力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.|||更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字 2%，可在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个劣迹斑斑的诈骗犯约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.|||请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（Trust me, babe）。在《回顾过去》（Look Back at it）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和说是个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.|||与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在20多岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。
Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners. So great to have you here for another episode, for another topic. One that I've wanted to discuss for some time, but it felt appropriate. And you lovely listeners thought the same way. So today we are going to discuss the stigma of being single. In 2023, when I am recording this episode, more people, I think, are single than ever before. In Australia, at least, I know it's like one in four or 25% of people. people over the age of 18 are single. And that number climbs when we look at the US or North America
Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners. So great to have you here for another episode, for another topic. One that I've wanted to discuss for some time, but it felt appropriate. And you lovely listeners thought the same way. So today we are going to discuss the stigma of being single. In 2023, when I am recording this episode, more people, I think, are single than ever before. In Australia, at least, I know it's like one in four or 25% of people. people over the age of 18 are single. And that number climbs when we look at the US or North America|||大家好，欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友。很高兴大家能来到这里收听又一期节目、探讨另一个话题。这个话题我已经想讨论一段时间了，现在觉得时机正好。你们这些可爱的听众也是这么想的。所以今天我们要讨论的是单身所承受的社会污名。在2023年我录制这期节目的时候，我认为单身的人比以往任何时候都要多。至少在澳大利亚，我知道大约有四分之一，即25%的人。18岁以上的人是单身。当我们把目光投向美国或北美时，这个数字还会攀升
or Europe. I think in some places, it's as high as like 35% totally against the historical norm. And yet sometimes it feels like it's a bit of an invisible group. And we face a lot of expectations to eventually want to settle down or to find our soulmate, both externally. and internally as well. I would say there is still this general sense that being single is a phase that we all want to get out of. It's not forever,
or Europe. I think in some places, it's as high as like 35% totally against the historical norm. And yet sometimes it feels like it's a bit of an invisible group. And we face a lot of expectations to eventually want to settle down or to find our soulmate, both externally. and internally as well. I would say there is still this general sense that being single is a phase that we all want to get out of. It's not forever,|||或欧洲。我认为在某些地方，这一比例甚至高达35%，这完全违背了历史常态。然而有时它感觉像是一个隐形的群体。我们面临着大量的期待，无论是来自外部还是内心，都希望最终能定下来或者找到自己的灵魂伴侣。我想说的是，人们普遍认为单身只是我们都想摆脱的一个阶段。它不是永远的，
and what we should all be aiming for is monogamy and a relationship. And that expectation becomes a lot more pronounced than I would also say internalized in our 20s. We may begin to feel a lot of shame or self-stigma for not having someone, or we feel drawn back into dating apps or serial dating to tick that partnership off our list. That has been my personal
and what we should all be aiming for is monogamy and a relationship. And that expectation becomes a lot more pronounced than I would also say internalized in our 20s. We may begin to feel a lot of shame or self-stigma for not having someone, or we feel drawn back into dating apps or serial dating to tick that partnership off our list. That has been my personal|||我们所有人追求的目标都应该是单一伴侣制和恋爱关系。这种期望变得更加明显，而且我想说，在我们20多岁时，它也更加内化了。我们可能会因为没有伴侣而感到许多羞耻或自我污名化，或者我们会发现自己再次被吸引回约会软件或连续约会中，以便在我们的清单上勾选掉“伴侣”这一项。这就是我的个人
experience, my last relationship if you have listened to me for a while. You'll know it left me very emotionally unavailable, I would say, for a long time. And I protected my peace a little too hard and being single has become a very comfortable part of my identity. But some of that, internalized misogyny, I would say, and that shame and that pressure to settle down has definitely been creeping in recently. This episode, and I guess my general thoughts on this, was also really inspired by some recent, like, events that have happened in my life. I went to a dinner party the other day for a very good friend of mine. No shame to her. I love her to bits. But I showed up at this party, and every single person there was in a relationship or had attended.
experience, my last relationship if you have listened to me for a while. You'll know it left me very emotionally unavailable, I would say, for a long time. And I protected my peace a little too hard and being single has become a very comfortable part of my identity. But some of that, internalized misogyny, I would say, and that shame and that pressure to settle down has definitely been creeping in recently. This episode, and I guess my general thoughts on this, was also really inspired by some recent, like, events that have happened in my life. I went to a dinner party the other day for a very good friend of mine. No shame to her. I love her to bits. But I showed up at this party, and every single person there was in a relationship or had attended.|||经历，如果你听我节目有一段时间了，就会知道我的上一段感情，可以说让我在很长一段时间里在情感上都处于封闭状态。我对内心的平静保护得有点过头了，单身已经成为我身份认同中非常舒适的一部分。但我可以说，内化厌女症的一部分，以及那种羞耻感和想要安定下来的压力，最近确实在悄悄侵蚀我的内心。这期节目，以及我对此的大致想法，其实也是受到我生活中最近发生的一些事情的启发。前几天我去参加了一个好朋友的晚宴。我对她没有任何贬意，我爱死她了。但当我出现在这个派对上时，里面的每一个人都在恋爱中，或者说都是
with their partner. And it just made me so aware of how alone I was. And maybe alone isn't the best word. It just made me consider my status as a single person and wonder whether I was really actually missing out or I was doing something wrong or I was in some way flawed. I've also just encountered more and more conversations and questions from friends or family or even acquaintances the older I get
with their partner. And it just made me so aware of how alone I was. And maybe alone isn't the best word. It just made me consider my status as a single person and wonder whether I was really actually missing out or I was doing something wrong or I was in some way flawed. I've also just encountered more and more conversations and questions from friends or family or even acquaintances the older I get|||带着伴侣出席的。这让我深刻意识到自己有多么孤单。也许“孤单”并不是最好的词。它只是让我审视自己作为单身者的状态，并开始怀疑我是否真的错过了什么，或者我是不是做错了什么，亦或是我在某种程度上有什么缺陷。随着年龄的增长，我也越来越多地遇到来自朋友、家人甚至熟人的谈话和提问
where that looming question always seems to come up. How's your dating life going? Is there anyone serious? And it feels weird to always have the same answer. And yet I am genuinely the happiest I have ever been in my life. I think here's the thing I've realized. No one can make you feel bad about something that you are comfortable with. And let me tell you, society is going to try and make you feel insecure about being single a million different ways. It's in the movies and the media we consume. It's in our childhood experiences, in the misogyny that we internalize, cultural norms, societal expectations into personal relationships, and also some of the structural and economic challenges that accompany being a single person in this society. But is it wrong to want a relationship?
where that looming question always seems to come up. How's your dating life going? Is there anyone serious? And it feels weird to always have the same answer. And yet I am genuinely the happiest I have ever been in my life. I think here's the thing I've realized. No one can make you feel bad about something that you are comfortable with. And let me tell you, society is going to try and make you feel insecure about being single a million different ways. It's in the movies and the media we consume. It's in our childhood experiences, in the misogyny that we internalize, cultural norms, societal expectations into personal relationships, and also some of the structural and economic challenges that accompany being a single person in this society. But is it wrong to want a relationship?|||那个挥之不去的问题似乎总会出现：你的感情生活怎么样？有认真的对象吗？每次都给出同样的答案感觉怪怪的。然而，我确实是我一生中最快乐的时期。我想我意识到了一点：没有人能让你对你感到舒适的事情感到难过。而且我必须告诉你，社会会试图通过上百万种不同的方式让你对单身感到缺乏安全感。它存在于我们消费的电影和媒体中。它存在于我们的童年经历中、在我们内化的厌女症中、文化规范中、社会对个人关系的期望中，以及伴随着在这个社会中作为一个单身者所面临的一些结构性和经济挑战中。但是，渴望一段恋爱关系是错的吗？
Is it wrong to feel insecure about your relationship status? Does that indicate that perhaps we're unhappy being alone, that somehow we aren't fulfilled without someone in our lives? And maybe one of the biggest questions of all, is my desire to be with someone actually a sign that I need to do more healing? Or am I only seeking a partnership because that's what society expects because of the shame, because of this whole social norm that I need to be married and I need to have someone in my life. A million thoughts, a million questions. Those are the things,
Is it wrong to feel insecure about your relationship status? Does that indicate that perhaps we're unhappy being alone, that somehow we aren't fulfilled without someone in our lives? And maybe one of the biggest questions of all, is my desire to be with someone actually a sign that I need to do more healing? Or am I only seeking a partnership because that's what society expects because of the shame, because of this whole social norm that I need to be married and I need to have someone in my life. A million thoughts, a million questions. Those are the things,|||对自己的感情状态感到没有安全感是错的吗？这是否表明也许我们独处并不快乐，如果没有人在我们的生活中，我们在某种程度上就无法得到满足？也许最大的问题之一是，我想要和某人在一起的愿望实际上是我需要进行更多疗愈的信号吗？还是说我寻找伴侣只是因为那是社会所期望的，是因为羞耻感，是因为我需要结婚、需要生命中有个伴侣的这种整体社会规范。无数的想法，无数的问题。这些就是，
those are the ideas that I really want to explore today. And this is not an episode that is going to scream in your face and claim you can't have a relationship or that a partnership will limit you. Absolutely not. What I really want to dive into is all the ways that we subliminally and implicitly feel convinced that a relationship is the only thing that will make us happy and that we are somehow less than without one. This time in our lives is so sacred and there is a genuine science that points to the value of our single years and it's information that I really want to share and I feel like it's really worth knowing. The stigma of being single is a live and well but it's not always other people who are making us feel bad about it.
those are the ideas that I really want to explore today. And this is not an episode that is going to scream in your face and claim you can't have a relationship or that a partnership will limit you. Absolutely not. What I really want to dive into is all the ways that we subliminally and implicitly feel convinced that a relationship is the only thing that will make us happy and that we are somehow less than without one. This time in our lives is so sacred and there is a genuine science that points to the value of our single years and it's information that I really want to share and I feel like it's really worth knowing. The stigma of being single is a live and well but it's not always other people who are making us feel bad about it.|||这些就是我今天真正想要探讨的想法。这期节目绝对不是那种冲着你的脸大喊大叫、声称你不能谈恋爱或者伴侣会限制你的节目。绝对不是。我真正想深入探讨的是，我们如何潜移默化、含蓄地确信恋爱关系是唯一能让我们快乐的事物，并且如果没有它，我们在某种程度上就低人一等。我们生命中的这段时光是如此神圣，确实有科学依据指出我们单身岁月的价值，这些信息我真的很想分享，而且我觉得非常值得了解。单身的社会污名依然存在且十分普遍，但并不总是别人让我们对此感到难过。
Sometimes the people who have the greatest stigma and feeling of, you know, discomfort towards our relationship status is ourselves. And when we're in our 20s, there is absolutely no reason to be feeling this way. So I really want to discuss why we do feel that pressure, what it means to feel stigma around your relationship status. Is it wrong to want a relationship status? And so many other questions in this episode. So without further ado, let's dive into it and unpack the stigma of being single in our 20s. I've talked about this before, but I think that our 20s are a real pivot decade where half the people in this age group are settling down or they have these very adult relationships. and the other half are kind of stuck in this perpetual loop of bad dates and failed situationships
Sometimes the people who have the greatest stigma and feeling of, you know, discomfort towards our relationship status is ourselves. And when we're in our 20s, there is absolutely no reason to be feeling this way. So I really want to discuss why we do feel that pressure, what it means to feel stigma around your relationship status. Is it wrong to want a relationship status? And so many other questions in this episode. So without further ado, let's dive into it and unpack the stigma of being single in our 20s. I've talked about this before, but I think that our 20s are a real pivot decade where half the people in this age group are settling down or they have these very adult relationships. and the other half are kind of stuck in this perpetual loop of bad dates and failed situationships|||有时，对我们的感情状态抱有最大污名感和，你知道的，不适感的人其实是我们自己。当我们处于20多岁的时候，完全没有理由去感受这种情绪。所以我真的很想讨论为什么我们会感受到这种压力，对自己的感情状态感到污名意味着什么。渴望一段感情状态是错的吗？以及本期节目中的许多其他问题。所以废话不多说，让我们深入探讨并剖析20多岁时单身的社会污名。我以前谈过这个，但我认为我们的20多岁是一个真正的转折十年，这个年龄段的一半人已经安定下来，或者拥有了非常成熟的恋爱关系，而另一半人则陷入了糟糕的约会和失败的暧昧关系中无法自拔
and dry spells. I can directly see this in the people around me. We're on one side. I have close friends who live with their partners and who are talking about marriage and children. And on the other side is people like me who feel woefully underprepared for this next stage. Sometimes we feel like our identity is tied to our relationship status. And we can't help but notice and crave the type of comfort and security of the people we see in these very happy relationships. I don't think that's necessarily a bad thing. It's not jealousy. There's not something inherently wrong with us. We psychologically crave what we don't have. It's scientifically proven and it has a very appropriate name. It's called the grass is greener syndrome. And this can
and dry spells. I can directly see this in the people around me. We're on one side. I have close friends who live with their partners and who are talking about marriage and children. And on the other side is people like me who feel woefully underprepared for this next stage. Sometimes we feel like our identity is tied to our relationship status. And we can't help but notice and crave the type of comfort and security of the people we see in these very happy relationships. I don't think that's necessarily a bad thing. It's not jealousy. There's not something inherently wrong with us. We psychologically crave what we don't have. It's scientifically proven and it has a very appropriate name. It’s called the grass is greener syndrome. And this can|||以及情感空白期。我在周围人身上能直接看到这一点。一方面，我有亲密的朋友和伴侣同居，谈论着婚姻和孩子。而另一方面，像我这样的人则觉得自己对这下一个阶段准备严重不足。有时我们会觉得自己的身份与感情状态息息相关。我们不禁会注意到并渴望那些身处幸福恋爱关系中的人们所拥有的那种舒适感和安全感。我认为这不一定是件坏事。这不是嫉妒。我们自身并没有什么本质上的错误。我们在心理上渴望我们所没有的东西。这是经过科学证实的，并且它有一个非常贴切的名字。它被称为“得不到的永远在骚动”综合征（grass is greener syndrome）。这也
also be explained by the scarcity effect. When we feel like something is desirable or worthwhile or rare, such as a relationship, our subconscious mind makes us want it more. So for example, when everyone around us has this beautiful partner or when we feel like the dating pool is slowly becoming a lot more limited and scarce such that, you know, the potential for a relationship is more rare, we crave them more because its value in our mind suddenly goes up. And that can really diminish our decision making and our standards because we do become desperate. We do feel like we are racing against the clock. I think there's also the fact that our society still very much values the idea of monogamy
also be explained by the scarcity effect. When we feel like something is desirable or worthwhile or rare, such as a relationship, our subconscious mind makes us want it more. So for example, when everyone around us has this beautiful partner or when we feel like the dating pool is slowly becoming a lot more limited and scarce such that, you know, the potential for a relationship is more rare, we crave them more because its value in our mind suddenly goes up. And that can really diminish our decision making and our standards because we do become desperate. We do feel like we are racing against the clock. I think there's also the fact that our society still very much values the idea of monogamy|||可以用稀缺效应来解释。当我们觉得某样东西令人向往、有价值或很罕见（比如恋爱关系）时，我们的潜意识就会让我们更渴望它。例如，当周围每个人都有一个优秀的伴侣时，或者当我们觉得约会池正在慢慢变得更加有限和稀缺，以至于你知道发展恋爱关系的潜力变得更加罕有时，我们会更加渴望它们，因为它们在我们心中的价值突然上升了。这确实会降低我们的决策能力和标准，因为我们确实变得绝望了。我们确实觉得自己是在与时间赛跑。我认为还有一个事实是，我们的社会仍然非常重视单一伴侣制的理念
and partnership. Being single is not the norm. And as this amazing article put it, it's more acceptable. to be part of a couple, even a dysfunctional one, then it is to be happy and content by yourself. There's a lot to be said about this and about where this comes from, the origins of this stigma. And if you're thinking that the use of the word stigma is perhaps a little bit dramatic,
and partnership. Being single is not the norm. And as this amazing article put it, it's more acceptable. to be part of a couple, even a dysfunctional one, then it is to be happy and content by yourself. There's a lot to be said about this and about where this comes from, the origins of this stigma. And if you're thinking that the use of the word stigma is perhaps a little bit dramatic,|||和伴侣关系。单身并不是常态。正如这篇精彩的文章所说：成为情侣的一部分（哪怕是不健康的伴侣关系），也比独自一人感到快乐和满足更能被社会接受。关于这一点，以及这种污名的来源，有很多话要说。如果你认为使用“污名”（stigma）这个词可能有点小题大做，
you may or may not be surprised by how much research has actually been conducted into this rising trend. I think the term stigma is used pretty broadly in psychology and in society to refer to negative attitudes towards someone based on a particular characteristic or an attribute. And it's also typically accompanied by false stereotypes such as, I don't know, spinster or old maid or cat lady. all of these stereotypes associated with singleness, particularly female singleness, really firmly plant people who choose to be single as inherently unhappy, as unsatisfied or to be looked down upon. So there is this amazing psychotherapist called Alison Abrams, and she has done a lot of thinking about this, and she says that single shaming is negatively judging somebody for not being partnered up. and not conforming to society's expectations to be married, or at least in a relationship by a certain age.
you may or may not be surprised by how much research has actually been conducted into this rising trend. I think the term stigma is used pretty broadly in psychology and in society to refer to negative attitudes towards someone based on a particular characteristic or an attribute. And it's also typically accompanied by false stereotypes such as, I don't know, spinster or old maid or cat lady. all of these stereotypes associated with singleness, particularly female singleness, really firmly plant people who choose to be single as inherently unhappy, as unsatisfied or to be looked down upon. So there is this amazing psychotherapist called Alison Abrams, and she has done a lot of thinking about this, and she says that single shaming is negatively judging somebody for not being partnered up.|||那么对于针对这一上升趋势究竟进行了多少研究，你可能会感到惊讶，也可能不会。我认为“污名”这个词在心理学和社会中被广泛用于指基于特定特征或属性对某人的负面态度。它通常还伴随着错误的刻板印象，比如，我不知道，老处女、老姑娘或猫女。所有这些与单身（尤其是女性单身）相关的刻板印象，确实深深地将那些选择单身的人归结为天生不快乐、不满足或应该被看不起的人。所以有一位出色的心理治疗师叫艾莉森·艾布拉姆斯（Alison Abrams），她对此进行了很多思考，她说单身羞辱是对没有伴侣的人进行负面评价。
And it manifests in a lot of implicit judgments and phrases that I'm sure we are probably familiar with. You know, you must be so lonely. The right person is out there for you. It's just a numbers game. You know, once you get to 30, it becomes a lot worse or, you know, you'll find someone eventually. when people make these statements, it may sound like encouragement or sympathy. But what they're really enforcing is that you kind of better get a move on because if you're not in a relationship, there must be something inherently missing in your life.
and not conforming to society's expectations to be married, or at least in a relationship by a certain age. And it manifests in a lot of implicit judgments and phrases that I'm sure we are probably familiar with. You know, you must be so lonely. The right person is out there for you. It's just a numbers game. You know, once you get to 30, it becomes a lot worse or, you know, you'll find someone eventually. when people make these statements, it may sound like encouragement or sympathy. But what they're really enforcing is that you kind of better get a move on because if you're not in a relationship, there must be something inherently missing in your life.|||并且不符合社会对在特定年龄前结婚或至少处于恋爱关系中的期望。它体现在许多含蓄的判断和短语中，我相信我们可能都非常熟悉。你知道的，“你一定很孤独。”“对的人就在外面等你。”“这只是概率问题。”你知道的，“一旦到了30岁，情况就会变得更糟”或者“你知道的，你总会找到人的。”当人们说出这些话时，听起来可能像是鼓励或同情。但他们真正强调的是，你最好快点行动，因为如果你没有恋爱，你的生活中一定有什么东西本质上缺失了。
And we can't fully believe that you are happy or secure until you conform and until you find that puzzle piece. I think it's pity. And pity derives from this inherent. belief that you must be suffering or that you're experiencing some grave misfortune. In a study conducted by match, research has found that of the common shaming phrases, 35% of single people were told that they would find someone soon, 29% had heard that they must be lonely, and 38% reported a general pity over their
And we can not fully believe that you are happy or secure until you conform and until you find that puzzle piece. I think it's pity. And pity derives from this inherent. belief that you must be suffering or that you're experiencing some grave misfortune. In a study conducted by match, research has found that of the common shaming phrases, 35% of single people were told that they would find someone soon, 29% had heard that they must be lonely, and 38% reported a general pity over their|||在我们看到你顺从并找到那块拼图之前，我们无法完全相信你是快乐或有安全感的。我认为这是怜悯。而怜悯源于这种根深蒂固的信念：你一定在受苦，或者你正在经历某种巨大的不幸。Match（知名交友网站）进行的一项研究发现，在常见的羞辱短语中，35%的单身人士被告知他们很快会找到伴侣，29%的人听到过他们一定很孤独，38%的人报告说对他们的感情状态普遍感受到了
relationship status. So why is that? Why do we still face? this implicit idea that in order to be happy, we have to be in love. We have seen a big change recently accompanying the acceptability of singlehood, both in attitudes and demographics, particularly amongst women. In the past, marriage was one of the only ways to really gain social power or even security. If you've read Pride and Prejudice or you've seen the movie, you'll know that infamous line. you know, I'm 27, I have no money, I have no prospects, I'm already a burden to my family, and I'm frightened. And that's a pretty accurate depiction of the choices of women in particular
relationship status. So why is that? Why do we still face? this implicit idea that in order to be happy, we have to be in love. We have seen a big change recently accompanying the acceptability of singlehood, both in attitudes and demographics, particularly amongst women. In the past, marriage was one of the only ways to really gain social power or even security. If you've read Pride and Prejudice or you've seen the movie, you'll know that infamous line. you know, I'm 27, I have no money, I have no prospects, I'm already a burden to my family, and I'm frightened. And that's a pretty accurate depiction of the choices of women in particular|||怜悯。这是为什么呢？为什么我们仍然面临这种含蓄的观念：为了快乐，我们必须恋爱。最近我们看到，伴随着单身的可接受度，态度和人口统计数据发生了巨大变化，尤其是在女性当中。在过去，婚姻是真正获得社会权力甚至安全感的唯一途径之一。如果你读过《傲慢与偏见》或者看过这部电影，你就会知道那句著名的台词。你知道的，“我27岁了，我没有钱，我没有前途，我已经成为我家庭的负担，我很害怕。”这相当准确地描绘了女性的选择，尤其是
back in the day. It was either marriage or it was poverty. And, you know, we can thank the suffragettes and first and second wave feminism for kind of liberating us from that belief. But as much as our society has experienced somewhat of a cultural and sexual, liberation in the last 50 years, it does take generations for stigma and certain expectations to be eliminated. There is still a typical normalized script for how our lives should run, that at its core is focused on obtaining partnership and starting a family. In some ways, this is evolutionary, you know, partnership provided offspring, which continued on our genetics and the survival of our species, and those offspring were more likely to survive if there were two people to take care of them.
back in the day. It was either marriage or it was poverty. And, you know, we can thank the suffragettes and first and second wave feminism for kind of liberating us from that belief. But as much as our society has experienced somewhat of a cultural and sexual, liberation in the last 50 years, it does take generations for stigma and certain expectations to be eliminated. There is still a typical normalized script for how our lives should run, that at its core is focused on obtaining partnership and starting a family. In some ways, this is evolutionary, you know, partnership provided offspring, which continued on our genetics and the survival of our species, and those offspring were more likely to survive if there were two people to take care of them.|||在那个年代。要么结婚，要么贫穷。而且，你知道，我们要感谢女性参政权论者以及第一和第二波女性主义者，她们把我们从那种信念中解放出来。但尽管我们的社会在过去50年中经历了一定程度的文化和性解放，但要消除污名和某些期望确实需要几代人的时间。对于我们的生活应该如何进行，仍然有一个典型的规范化剧本，其核心是获得伴侣关系和建立家庭。在某些方面，这是进化的结果，你知道的，伴侣提供了后代，这延续了我们的基因和物种的生存，如果有两个人照顾他们，这些后代就更有可能生存下来。
In other ways, it's very cultural. Some, you know, still consider women over the age of 30 who are single to be left over. And we implicitly do place couples or partnership on a pedestal because they have met the blueprint of what our society expects. They have done what they've been told to do, which is to find each other and to hold on to each other. And maybe the reason why there is such an obvious pressure, even do this before 30,
In other ways, it's very cultural. Some, you know, still consider women over the age of 30 who are single to be left over. And we implicitly do place couples or partnership on a pedestal because they have met the blueprint of what our society expects. They have done what they've been told to do, which is to find each other and to hold on to each other. And maybe the reason why there is such an obvious pressure, even do this before 30,|||在其他方面，这是非常文化的。你知道，有些人仍然认为30岁以上的单身女性是“剩女”。我们潜意识里确实将情侣或伴侣关系放在了神坛上，因为他们符合我们社会所期望的蓝图。他们做了他们被告知要做的事情，那就是找到彼此并紧紧相依。也许为什么会有如此明显的压力，甚至要在30岁之前做到这一点，
is because of our cultural and our biological awareness of fertility. There are so many justifications, but I think that a biological explanation actually eliminates some of the societal responsibility for this implicit stigma against single people. And we cannot talk about this stigma without examining the psychology behind gender and misogyny. Like most things in society, like most stigma,
is because of our cultural and our biological awareness of fertility. There are so many justifications, but I think that a biological explanation actually eliminates some of the societal responsibility for this implicit stigma against single people. And we cannot talk about this stigma without examining the psychology behind gender and misogyny. Like most things in society, like most stigma,|||是因为我们对生育的文化和生物学认知。有这么多的理由，但我认为生物学解释实际上消除了社会对这种针对单身人士的含蓄污名的一部分责任。我们在讨论这种污名时，不能不审视性别和厌女症背后的心理学。就像社会中的大多数事情一样，就像大多数污名一样，
single shaming is not equally distributed. Think about the words used to describe singleness past 30. A woman is a spinster, a man is a bachelor. And words are not empty constructs. They contain an implied social message and a meaning, a certain tone. Women tend to endure the most shame or prejudice because of the emphasis on marriage and child rearing. And we can understand this by looking at gender schema theory.
single shaming is not equally distributed. Think about the words used to describe singleness past 30. A woman is a spinster, a man is a bachelor. And words are not empty constructs. They contain an implied social message and a meaning, a certain tone. Women tend to endure the most shame or prejudice because of the emphasis on marriage and child rearing. And we can understand this by looking at gender schema theory.|||单身羞辱并不是平均分布的。想想用来描述30岁以后单身的词汇。女人被称为老处女（spinster），男人被称为单身汉（bachelor）。词汇并非空洞的建构。它们包含着隐含的社会信息、意义和某种语气。由于对婚姻和抚养孩子的强调，女性往往承受最多的羞耻或偏见。我们可以通过观察性别图式理论（gender schema theory）来理解这一点。
So gender schema theory, it was introduced in the 1980s by this amazing psychologist. Her name is Sandra Bem, a central reading, you should go and look her up. And this theory essentially says that the binary or the suggested differences between male and female have become one of the basic organizational structures of human society. whereby men are the breadwinners, the money makers, the leaders, the powerful sex, and women are the wives. They're the homemakers. They're the mothers. As children, we learn about gender through these specific attributes, and we create gender schemers. And a schema is essentially a pattern of thought or behavior that's used to organize categories or to simplify our interpretation of the world.
So gender schema theory, it was introduced in the 1980s by this amazing psychologist. Her name is Sandra Bem, a central reading, you should go and look her up. And this theory essentially says that the binary or the suggested differences between male and female have become one of the basic organizational structures of human society. whereby men are the breadwinners, the money makers, the leaders, the powerful sex, and women are the wives. They're the homemakers. They're the mothers. As children, we learn about gender through these specific attributes, and we create gender schemers. And a schema is essentially a pattern of thought or behavior that's used to organize categories or to simplify our interpretation of the world.|||所以性别图式理论是这位杰出的心理学家在20世纪80年代提出的。她的名字叫桑德拉·贝姆（Sandra Bem），这是一篇核心阅读材料，你们应该去查阅一下。该理论基本上认为，男性和女性的二元对立或暗示的差异已经成为人类社会的基本组织结构之一。即男性是顶梁柱、赚钱者、领导者、强势性别，而女性是妻子。她们是家庭主妇。她们是母亲。作为孩子，我们通过这些特定属性来了解性别，并建立性别图式。图式本质上是一种用于组织类别或简化我们对世界的理解的思想或行为模式。
If you were born a girl, you're implicitly influenced by well. what you observe, by how your behavior is corrected, by the media you consume, the words of your peers and adults, the behavior of your parents, so many things. You know, if you were raised in a traditional culture, there may have been very strict divisions between men and women. Women belonged to the private sphere, to the home. They took care of the household and they raised children, whilst men had access to the public sphere. They worked outside the the home to support the family. And when we are raised in this culture, which I think is every culture in some way or another, we develop gender schema in line with what we observe. And through
If you were born a girl, you're implicitly influenced by well. what you observe, by how your behavior is corrected, by the media you consume, the words of your peers and adults, the behavior of your parents, so many things. You know, if you were raised in a traditional culture, there may have been very strict divisions between men and women. Women belonged to the private sphere, to the home. They took care of the household and they raised children, whilst men had access to the public sphere. They worked outside the the home to support the family. And when we are raised in this culture, which I think is every culture in some way or another, we develop gender schema in line with what we observe. And through|||如果你生为女孩，你会潜移默化地受到以下因素的影响：你所观察到的事物、你的行为如何被纠正、你消费的媒体、同龄人和成年人的话语、父母的行为，等等太多了。你知道的，如果你在一个传统文化中长大，男女之间可能会有非常严格的分工。女性属于私人领域，属于家庭。她们操持家务、抚养孩子，而男性则可以进入公共领域。他们在户外工作以养家糊口。当我们在这种文化中长大时（我认为这是以某种方式存在的每一种文化），我们就会根据我们所观察到的东西形成性别图式。并通过
this schema, we develop an understanding of what we can do to be a woman or to be a man, of what society expects from us. And when you act in line with those expectations, your behavior is reinforced. You are praised. You are told you're pretty. You are told that you're good such that you become conditioned to embrace a certain gender identity and expression. And a big part of the equation of being woman, of that identity that we learn is being a wife and being a mother. And we often construct the identity of a woman based on her relationship to others and her social role. And because of those very early and consistent influences, it does feel like a natural duty for you to live up to those expectations, to fulfill that role. And who are we
this schema, we develop an understanding of what we can do to be a woman or to be a man, of what society expects from us. And when you act in line with those expectations, your behavior is reinforced. You are praised. You are told you're pretty. You are told that you're good such that you become conditioned to embrace a certain gender identity and expression. And a big part of the equation of being woman, of that identity that we learn is being a wife and being a mother. And we often construct the identity of a woman based on her relationship to others and her social role. And because of those very early and consistent influences, it does feel like a natural duty for you to live up to those expectations, to fulfill that role. And who are we|||这个图式，我们逐渐理解了做什么才能成为一个女人或一个男人，理解了社会对我们的期望。当你按照这些期望行事时，你的行为就会得到强化。你受到表扬。有人夸你漂亮。有人夸你乖巧，以至于你习惯于接受某种性别认同和表达。成为女人这个等式的重要组成部分，即我们所学到的身份认同，就是做妻子和做母亲。我们经常根据女性与他人的关系以及她的社会角色来构建女性的身份。正是由于这些非常早期且持续的影响，你确实会觉得不辜负这些期望、扮演好那个角色是一种天经地义的责任。如果没有了丈夫、伴侣、孩子，我们又是谁呢？
without a husband, without a mate, without a child? So we really feel shame around being single, because we're not living up to what we know is expected of us. We're not fulfilling that role, that trope that has been sold to us since we were children. It's also important to examine the continuing and I'd say maintaining influence of the media and television. The media, I would say, is the main way that societal norms are reinforced. There's even a whole new discipline in psychology known as media psychology that looks into the impact of the media on our perspective of the world and the role of online learning. So there is this infamous study. If you're a psychology student, you will definitely have come across this, but it found that when children were
without a husband, without a mate, without a child? So we really feel shame around being single, because we're not living up to what we know is expected of us. We're not fulfilling that role, that trope that has been sold to us since we were children. It's also important to examine the continuing and I'd say maintaining influence of the media and television. The media, I would say, is the main way that societal norms are reinforced. There's even a whole new discipline in psychology known as media psychology that looks into the impact of the media on our perspective of the world and the role of online learning. So there is this infamous study. If you're a psychology student, you will definitely have come across this, but it found that when children were|||因此，我们对单身感到真正的羞耻，因为我们没有达到我们所知道的社会对我们的期望。我们没有履行那个从小向我们兜售的角色和老套情节。审视媒体和电视持续的、可以说是一直在维护的影响也很重要。我想说，媒体是强化社会规范的主要途径。心理学甚至有一个全新的学科，被称为媒体心理学（media psychology），它研究媒体对我们世界观的影响以及在线学习的作用。所以有一个著名的研究。如果你是一名心理学学生，你肯定遇到过这个研究，但它发现当儿童
exposed to, for example, violence on television or violent video games, they were more likely to be aggressive towards their peers because they believed it was socially acceptable, and they modelled their behavior on these displays. And we can make that same connection with the presentation of singleness as a concept in television and movies. Okay, let me list a few movies for you. Bridget Jones's Diary. The proposal with Sandra Bullock, a very good movie, I will say. 27 dresses. 10 things I hate about you. The Devil Wears Prada. You want to know what all these movies have in common? They all peddle a really familiar narrative and storyline. There is a woman who is focused on herself, who was successful, who was career-driven, who at many times is
exposed to, for example, television violence or violent video games, they were more likely to be aggressive towards their peers because they believed it was socially acceptable, and they modelled their behavior on these displays. And we can make that same connection with the presentation of singleness as a concept in television and movies. Okay, let me list a few movies for you. Bridget Jones's Diary. The proposal with Sandra Bullock, a very good movie, I will say. 27 dresses. 10 things I hate about you. The Devil Wears Prada. You want to know what all these movies have in common? They all peddle a really familiar narrative and storyline. There is a woman who is focused on herself, who was successful, who was career-driven, who at many times is|||接触到诸如电视暴力或暴力电子游戏时，他们更有可能对同龄人表现出攻击性，因为他们认为这是社会所接受的，并且他们根据这些表现来模仿自己的行为。我们可以将这种联系同样应用到电视和电影中单身概念的呈现上。好吧，我给大家列举几部电影。《BJ单身日记》（Bridget Jones's Diary）。桑德拉·布洛克主演的《假结婚》（The proposal），这是一部非常好的电影。《27套礼服》（27 dresses）。《我恨你的十件事》（10 things I hate about you）。《穿普拉达的女王》（The Devil Wears Prada）。你想知道所有这些电影的共同点是什么吗？它们都在兜售一个非常熟悉的叙事和故事情节。有一个专注于自我、成功、事业心强的女性，她在很多时候
quite content being alone, but she needs a boyfriend or a husband to complete her, to tame her. And when she finds him, she's happy. And that's when the story kind of ends. Once you begin to recognize that pattern, I think there's no wonder that we feel less than if we aren't in a relationship. A relationship, marriage, it's presented as the end game. You know, what more more is there to a successful story, to a happy ending, then a wedding, then a ring. And if that's not enough to reinforce the stigma of singleness, our society also makes it much harder for those of us who are not in relationships. I think a lot of our cultural context and how our society operates is built on the concept
quite content being alone, but she needs a boyfriend or a husband to complete her, to tame her. And when she finds him, she's happy. And that's kind of ends. Once you begin to recognize that pattern, I think there's no wonder that we feel less than if we aren't in a relationship. A relationship, marriage, it's presented as the end game. You know, what more more is there to a successful story, to a happy ending, then a wedding, then a ring. And if that's not enough to reinforce the stigma of singleness, our society also makes it much harder for those of us who are not in relationships. I think a lot of our cultural context and how our society operates is built on the concept|||对独处相当满意，但她需要一个男朋友或丈夫来让她完整，来驯服她。当她找到他时，她就幸福了。故事也就差不多这样结束了。一旦你开始认出这种模式，我想难怪如果我们没有恋爱，就会觉得自己低人一等。恋爱、婚姻，它被呈现为最终的结局。你知道的，对于一个成功的故事、一个美好的结局来说，除了婚礼和戒指，还能有什么更重要的呢？如果这还不足以强化单身的污名，我们的社会也让那些不处于恋爱关系中的人变得更加艰难。我认为我们的许多文化背景以及我们的社会运作方式都是建立在
of the nuclear family, or at least some form of partnership. You know, think about buying a home. These days, I think you need two incomes to do that. So that economic security provided by marriage back in the 1600s, it's still very much around. It's just been repackaged and rebranded. You know, some other examples, insurance, it's cheaper for couples. Being married is great for tax purposes.
of the nuclear family, or at least some form of partnership. You know, think about buying a home. These days, I think you need two incomes to do that. So that economic security provided by marriage back in the 1600s, it's still very much around. It's just been repackaged and rebranded. You know, some other examples, insurance, it's cheaper for couples. Being married is great for tax purposes.|||核心家庭的概念之上的，或者至少是某种形式的伴侣关系之上。你知道的，想想买房吧。如今，我认为你需要双收入才能做到这一点。因此，早在17世纪由婚姻提供的经济安全感在今天依然存在。它只是被重新打包和赋予了新的品牌形象。你知道，其他一些例子，保险，对情侣来说更便宜。为了税务目的，结婚是非常棒的。
And there's even been this term kind of coined for those policies called Singalism. So the policy of making, single people pay more than couples for their basic needs as a way of kind of nudging people towards partnership through this positive reinforcement and as a way to kind of make people feel like they have to conform and fit into this box. I think when you look at all those factors, there's no wonder that we feel terrible for being alone. In so many ways, you know, from social schemers to the media to economic security,
And there's even been this term kind of coined for those policies called Singalism. So the policy of making, single people pay more than couples for their basic needs as a way of kind of nudging people towards partnership through this positive reinforcement and as a way to kind of make people feel like they have to conform and fit into this box. I think when you look at all those factors, there's no wonder that we feel terrible for being alone. In so many ways, you know, from social schemers to the media to economic security,|||甚至还有一个专门为这些政策创造的词叫“单身歧视”（Singalism）。因此，这项政策让单身人士为他们的基本需求支付比情侣更多的费用，以此作为通过这种正强化来推动人们走向伴侣关系的一种方式，并以此让人觉得他们必须顺从并融入这个框架。我想当你看到所有这些因素时，难怪我们会因为独处而感到糟糕。在许多方面，你知道，从社会图式到媒体再到经济安全，
society is actively implying that if you are single, you are somehow not really made to fit into this society. This is not acceptable. And when we begin to internalize these beliefs, we no longer need others to tell us that will never be happy if we're alone. Because we start to believe it ourselves and apply that stigma in our own right. This is known in psychology as self-stigma, in contrast to public stigma. If we are exposed to enough conditioning and negative beliefs, we begin to self-regulate
society is actively implying that if you are single, you are somehow not really made to fit into this society. This is not acceptable. And when we begin to internalize these beliefs, we no longer need others to tell us that will never be happy if we're alone. Because we start to believe it ourselves and apply that stigma in our own right. This is known in psychology as self-stigma, in contrast to public stigma. If we are exposed to enough conditioning and negative beliefs, we begin to self-regulate|||社会都在积极地暗示：如果你是单身，你在某种程度上并不真正适合这个社会。这是不可接受的。当我们开始将这些信念内化时，我们不再需要别人告诉我们，如果我们独处就永远不会快乐。因为我们自己开始相信这一点，并理所当然地将这种污名施加在自己身上。这在心理学上被称为自我污名（self-stigma），与公众污名（public stigma）相对。如果我们暴露在足够的洗脑和消极信念中，我们就会开始自我调节
and we internalize that negative stereotype. We internalize that belief that we should not be satisfied, that we should be looking for someone. And that's where a lot of the shame comes from. You know, I haven't, I really need to do a whole episode on this because I think that shame is such a powerful emotion and we feel shame when we feel like we have violated a social norm and it makes us view ourselves in a negative light or feel like we are flawed for not fulfilling some kind of social duty or expectation and our proneness to this shame it's influenced by a lot
and we internalize that negative stereotype. We internalize that belief that we should not be satisfied, that we should be looking for someone. And that's where a lot of the shame comes from. You know, I haven't, I really need to do a whole episode on this because I think that shame is such a powerful emotion and we feel shame when we feel like we have violated a social norm and it makes us view ourselves in a negative light or feel like we are flawed for not fulfilling some kind of social duty or expectation and our proneness to this shame it's influenced by a lot|||并将这种负面的刻板印象内化。我们将这样一种信念内化：我们不应该满足，我们应该去寻找某人。这就是许多羞耻感的来源。你知道的，我还没有……我真的需要就此做一整期节目，因为我认为羞耻感是一种非常强大的情绪，当我们觉得违背了社会规范时就会感到羞耻，这让我们以消极的眼光看待自己，或者觉得自己因为没有履行某种社会责任或期望而有缺陷，而我们对这种羞耻感的易感性受到很多
of factors but according to researchers from the university of burn in germany they did this really interesting study where they found that younger people in particular, between the ages of 18 and 29, and women as well, are much more impacted by the consequences and the experiences of shame. And I think that is the target audience for the stigma around being single. Women between 18 and 29. And as much as you may, you know, really love your single era. You're embracing your alone time. you're really loving that you can put effort into your friendships and your hobbies and your dreams.
of factors, but according to researchers from the university of burn in germany they did this really interesting study where they found that younger people in particular, between the ages of 18 and 29, and women as well, are much more impacted by the consequences and the experiences of shame. And I think that is the target audience for the stigma around being single. Women between 18 and 29. And as much as you may, you know, really love your single era. You're embracing your alone time. you're really loving that you can put effort into your friendships and your hobbies and your dreams.|||因素的影响，但根据德国伯尔尼大学（University of Bern）研究人员的一项非常有趣的研究，他们发现年轻人（尤其是18至29岁之间的人）以及女性，受羞耻感后果和经历的影响要大得多。我认为这正是单身污名的目标受众。18至29岁之间的女性。尽管你可能，你知道的，真的很喜欢你的单身时代。你在享受独处的时间。你真的很喜欢能够把精力投入到友谊、爱好和梦想中。
Sometimes we can't ignore that little voice in the back of our head that is waiting for the right person to come along, that is dreaming of love and dreaming of partnership. So does that kind of mean that we've succumbed to public stigma and that we've internalized the belief that we need to be in a relationship? I guess is it wrong to still want to be with someone? Is it wrong to be in a relationship? Or is that just an acknowledgement that we do feel shame? I really want to unpack that because I think that that is really fascinating.
Sometimes we can't ignore that little voice in the back of our head that is waiting for the right person to come along, that is dreaming of love and dreaming of partnership. So does that kind of mean that we've succumbed to public stigma and that we've internalized the belief that we need to be in a relationship? I guess is it wrong to still want to be with someone? Is it wrong to be in a relationship? Or is that just an acknowledgement that we do feel shame? I really want to unpack that because I think that that is really fascinating.|||有时我们无法忽视脑海深处那个微弱的声音：它在等待对的人出现，它在梦想着爱情和伴侣关系。那么这是否意味着我们屈服于公众污名，并且我们将“我们需要谈恋爱”这一信念内化了呢？我想问，依然想和某人在一起是错的吗？谈恋爱是错的吗？还是这只是一种承认，即我们确实感到了羞耻？我真的很想剖析这一点，因为我认为这真的非常吸引人。
I think that we can both recognize that there is a certain social and public stigma around singleness and still want to experience love and partnership. So we're going to discuss all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
I think that we can both recognize that there is a certain social and public stigma around singleness and still want to experience love and partnership. So we're going to discuss all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.|||我认为我们既可以认识到单身存在某种社会和公众污名，同时又依然渴望体验爱情和伴侣关系。因此，在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗挫力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.|||我们曾坚信植物油天生具有炎性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字 T-W-O-Persent，可在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of...
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of...|||我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at it）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）合作的节目，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为……
crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?|||快克可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，不过只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把话说完。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.|||是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了呼应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在我心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,|||我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了样东西。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的竞赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,|||是因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要，还是因为你害怕才去做一个好人？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），我们将就疗愈、
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct?
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct?|||成长、父职、压力和目标展开真实的对话，尽在我的新播客《以艰难的方式学习》。打开你的免费 iHeartRadio 应用程序，搜索“learning a hard way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》（The Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法院听证会暴露出她故事中惊人的矛盾之处。这引发了长达数年的法庭之争以证明真相。你曾篡改过某人的特定测试两次，对吗？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.|||我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·莱斯皮安（Gregalespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我震惊了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice|||我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在正义伸张之前，这一切都还没有结束
is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Wanting to be in a relationship does not mean that you are abandoning yourself. I read that the other day and I didn't really know how I felt about it. I think when you are someone who is single, especially in your 20s, in order to kind of replace that cognitive dissonance of perhaps wanting love and not be. being able to find it, we can create a very apathetic exterior. Maybe this is familiar to you.
is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Wanting to be in a relationship does not mean that you are abandoning yourself. I read that the other day and I didn't really know how I felt about it. I think when you are someone who is single, especially in your 20s, in order to kind of replace that cognitive dissonance of perhaps wanting love and not be. being able to find it, we can create a very apathetic exterior. Maybe this is familiar to you.|||亚利桑那州。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。渴望恋爱并不意味着你在抛弃自我。我前几天读到这句话，当时我并不太清楚自己对此作何感想。我想，当你是一个单身人士时，尤其是当你处于20多岁时，为了弥补那种“既渴望爱又找不到”的认知失调，我们可能会表现出一种非常冷漠的外表。也许你对这一点并不陌生。
You know, that pattern of telling your friends, you know, I don't need anyone and men are trash and love is a lie and I'm never settling down. And perhaps that's true and power to you. But what I've personally found is that deep down, we kind of know we don't believe it. We kind of know that we do want to conform to that narrative. It's really an armour that we use to protect us from being hurt again. If we appear detached to others, perhaps we can convince ourselves and that we are, and we know that we can protect ourselves from being hurt. It can also be seen as kind of this protest against society's obsession with partnership and monogamy and that repetitive narrative that love is the point of living. but does craving that relationship, that partnership, does that inherently mean that you're not
You know, that pattern of telling your friends, you know, I don't need anyone and men are trash and love is a lie and I'm never settling down. And perhaps that's true and power to you. But what I've personally found is that deep down, we kind of know we don't believe it. We kind of know that we do want to conform to that narrative. It's really an armour that we use to protect us from being hurt again. If we appear detached to others, perhaps we can convince ourselves and that we are, and we know that we can protect ourselves from being hurt. It can also be seen as kind of this protest against society's obsession with partnership and monogamy and that repetitive narrative that love is the point of living. but does craving that relationship, that partnership, does that inherently mean that you're not|||你知道的，那种对朋友说的话的模式：“我不需要任何人，男人都是垃圾，爱情是个谎言，我绝不会安定下来。”也许那是真的，祝你力量爆棚。但我个人发现的是，在内心深处，我们其实知道自己并不相信这一点。我们隐约知道自己确实想要顺从那种叙事。这实际上是我们用来保护自己免受再次伤害的一层盔甲。如果我们对别人表现得冷漠疏离，也许我们就能说服自己（事实也确实如此），并且我们知道我们可以保护自己免受伤害。它也可以被看作是对社会对伴侣关系和单一伴侣制的痴迷，以及“爱是生活的意义”这种重复叙事的一种抗议。但是，渴望那种恋爱关系、那种伴侣关系，这是否本质上意味着你
happy alone or is it something else? I want to discuss that because firstly, I think it's absolutely okay and in fact highly normal if you do dream of finding your person. I know that we have spoken a lot about the stigma to conform and the societal expectations, but sometimes it does just come down to some super rudimentary. basic neuroscience. Humans rely subconsciously on others for security. We rely on them for recognition and love, and the presence of these things in our lives brings us an important psychological sense of comfort and safety. It kind of all derives from our innate human urge for belongingness.
happy alone or is it something else? I want to discuss that because firstly, I think it's absolutely okay and in fact highly normal if you do dream of finding your person. I know that we have spoken a lot about the stigma to conform and the societal expectations, but sometimes it does just come down to some super rudimentary. basic neuroscience. Humans rely subconsciously on others for security. We rely on them for recognition and love, and the presence of these things in our lives brings us an important psychological sense of comfort and safety. It kind of all derives from our innate human urge for belongingness.|||独处得并不快乐，还是说另有原因？我想讨论这一点，因为首先，我认为如果你梦想找到属于自己的人，这绝对是可以的，事实上也是非常正常的。我知道我们已经谈了很多关于顺从的污名和社会期望，但有时它真的只归结于一些超级初级、基本的神经科学。人类潜意识里依靠他人来获取安全感。我们依靠他们来获得认可和爱，这些事物在我们生活中的存在给我们带来了重要的心理舒适感和安全感。这一切都源于人类对归属感的先天冲动。
And when we look at Maslow's hierarchy of needs, for example, belongingness and intimate relationships are a critical psychological need that is required to be satisfied before we can reach self-actualization. And a lack of belongingness or a failure to maintain at least a minimum amount of lasting, positive, and significant relationships can have an impact on our mental well-being, but also our ability to achieve our highest selves. There was this really amazing article in psychology today, which I'll link in the show notes. And it really explains is quite well. It says that the need to belong goes beyond the need for superficial social ties or casual sexual connections. We want a profound bond. And when we feel that that is absent,
And when we look at Maslow's hierarchy of needs, for example, belongingness and intimate relationships are a critical psychological need that is required to be satisfied before we can reach self-actualization. And a lack of belongingness or a failure to maintain at least a minimum amount of lasting, positive, and significant relationships can have an impact on our mental well-being, but also our ability to achieve our highest selves. There was this really amazing article in psychology today, which I'll link in the show notes. And it really explains is quite well. It says that the need to belong goes beyond the need for superficial social ties or casual sexual connections. We want a profound bond. And when we feel that that is absent,|||当我们看马斯洛的需求层次理论（Maslow's hierarchy of needs）时，例如，归属感和亲密关系是至关重要的心理需求，必须在实现自我实现之前得到满足。缺乏归属感或未能保持至少最低限度的持久、积极和有意义的的关系，可能会对我们的心理健康以及我们实现最高自我的能力产生影响。在《今日心理学》（Psychology Today）上有一篇非常棒的文章，我会在节目文稿中附上链接。它对此解释得相当好。文章指出，对归属感的需求超越了对表面社交联系或随意的性连接的需求。我们需要一种深刻的纽带。当我们觉得这种纽带缺失时，
we inherently feel like something is lacking from our lives and we feel unhappy. I also think, let's not kid ourselves here. Love feels great. Scientifically, of course, we can talk about oxytocin. We can talk about dopamine. We can talk about serotonin. But it just feels really nice. It's also not the only thing that feels really nice. And it's not the only thing that can fulfill that psychological need for belongingness. There are so many other aspects of our lives that fit that profile, that match that requirement. You know, deep, meaningful friendships and familial closeness and shared jokes and memories and platonic soulmates, I think the problem with desiring a relationship comes when we implicitly or unconsciously believe that a partner will replace
我们生来就会觉得生活中缺少了什么，因而感到不快乐。我也觉得，我们别自欺欺人了。恋爱感觉确实好极了。从科学上讲，我们当然可以谈论催产素，可以谈论多巴胺，可以谈论血清素。但这种感觉真的很美好。而且，这并非唯一感觉美好的事物，也不是唯一能满足归属感这一心理需求的事物。在我们生活中，有太多其他方面契合这一模式、符合这一要求。比如，深厚而有意义的友谊、家庭的亲密感、共同的笑话与回忆，以及精神上的灵魂伴侣。我认为，渴望恋爱的问题在于，当我们含蓄地或无意识地认为伴侣会替代
our need for that more complex, diverse sense of belonging. For example, you know, using a relationship as a band-aid for loneliness, I think in some instances we do use romantic partners as kind of this symbolic proxy coping mechanism or a distraction. And when that occurs, I think we see the greatest correlation to things like codependency, but also identity fusion. Identity fusion, it normally relates to in-group loyalty, but we can also examine it on an individual level. So it's this kind of visceral, psychological sense of a oneness with another person. And what that can create and what that can cause is for us to entirely eliminate our own identity and sense of self in devotion to what is best for others or in this case what is best for our relationship and what is best for our partner.
我们对那种更复杂、更多元化的归属感的需求时。例如，将恋爱关系用作缓解孤独的创可贴。我认为，在某些情况下，我们确实将浪漫伴侣当作一种象征性的替代应对机制或一种分心方式。当这种情况发生时，我们就会看到它与共生依赖以及身份融合等现象产生极大的相关性。身份融合通常与内群体忠诚有关，但我们也可以在个人层面上对其进行审视。因此，这是一种发自内心的、心理上的与另一个人合二为一的感觉。这可能造成并导致的结果是，为了追求对他人最好的人，或者在本案中为了追求对我们的关系最好、对我们的伴侣最好的人，我们完全抹杀了自身的身份和自我意识。
When we feel a sense of unease in our self or loneliness, perhaps a lack of personal fulfillment, we may find that we are more likely to choose people who can aid in that insecurity, who can make us feel loved. And the same can be said for low self-esteem when we don't feel confident enough. We use the validation of others, including love and attraction, as an alternative to the internal validation that we lack and we can become dependent on that feeling. I always think that this kind of offers an explanation for those people who jump from one relationship to another as a coping mechanism rather than doing some of that deeper, dirty work. that and I think the combined stigma of being single offers a pretty accurate explanation
当我们内心情绪不安或感到孤独，或者也许缺乏个人成就感时，我们可能会发现，自己更有可能选择那些能够帮助我们排解这种不安全感、能让我们感受到爱的人。对于缺乏自信的自卑心理，情况也是如此。我们将他人的肯定（包括爱与吸引力）作为我们所缺乏的内部肯定的替代品，并可能对这种感觉产生依赖。我一直认为，这种现象为那些从一段恋情跳到另一段恋情的人提供了一种解释，他们将其作为一种应对机制，而不是去下苦功夫进行更深层次的内在清理。而且我认为，单身所带来的综合污名，为
for why we stay in dead-end relationships or why we feel this like urge to just like find someone and date them and be with them, even when they don't actually enhance our lives. So that kind of leads me to the next question. In a society where marriage and monogamy are very enviable and they are placed on this pedestal, do we have to be completely healed before pursuing a relationship to kind of ensure that we're doing so for the right reasons, not just to meet some cultural or societal norm? I have a lot of opinions on this because I think there are two kind of camps or schools of thought. The first is that you need to heal completely before entering into a new relationship.
我们为什么会停留在毫无结果的恋爱关系中，或者为什么我们会产生这种冲动，非要找个人约会并和他们在一起——即使他们实际上并没有让我们的生活变得更好——提供了一个相当准确的解释。这就引出了我的下一个问题。在一个将婚姻和一夫一妻制视为令人艳羡并将其奉若神明的社会里，我们在追求恋爱关系之前，是否必须完全治愈自己，以确保我们这样做是为了正确的原因，而不仅仅是为了迎合某种文化或社会规范？关于这一点，我有许多看法，因为我认为存在两种阵营或思想流派。第一种是，在进入一段新的恋情之前，你需要彻底治愈自己。
And the second is that a relationship in itself can be healing. I do believe that what you don't address when you are single, particularly around attachment issues and trust and understanding your values and standards, those conflicts and those kind of problems will show up in your next relationship. But that doesn't mean that you need to be completely perfect to pursue healthy connection. You just need to be cognizant of what triggers you, of what upsets you, and how you typically react to those triggers. For example, a common one we see with an anxious attachment style is a fear of abandonment, and that may manifest in extreme anxiety and pulling away at the slightest sign that someone is planning to leave you, even if it's as innocent as not replying to your messages straight away.
第二种是，恋爱关系本身就具有治愈作用。我确实相信，当你单身时没有解决的问题，特别是围绕依恋问题、信任以及理解你的价值观和标准的问题，这些冲突和那种问题会在你的下一段恋情中再次出现。但这并不意味着你需要十全十美才能去追求健康的亲密关系。你只需要清楚什么会触动你的痛点、什么会让你心烦意乱，以及你通常对这些触发因素有何反应。例如，我们在焦虑型依恋风格中常见的一种情况是对被抛弃的恐惧，这可能表现为极度焦虑，并在别人哪怕表现出一点点打算离开你的迹象时就退缩，哪怕这只是像没有立即回复你的信息这样无害的小事。
I was actually talking to a good friend of mine about this the other day. We've both definitely been through the ringer, I would say, with a series of very emotionally unavailable men. And as a result, I think both of us kind of have this tendency to have one foot out the door whenever we enter into a new relationship. For example, if you follow me on Instagram, you'll know this, but I've been dating a bit recently. And I've been going on a few dates with this guy. And one night, he was like, just letting you know, I'm going to be really busy for the next few weeks. And my first thought was like, liar. I know what that means. And my second thought was like run, ice amount, block his number, which is an entirely disproportionate response to the
前几天我实际上还在跟我的一个好朋友谈论这件事。可以说，我们俩都经历过一系列情感极其冷漠的男人的折磨。因此，我认为我们俩在进入一段新恋情时，都有点倾向于“脚踩两只船”或者说随时准备抽身。例如，如果你关注我的Instagram，你就会知道这一点，我最近一直在约会。我和这个男生约会了几次。有一天，他发消息说：“跟你说一声，接下来的几周我会非常忙。”我的第一反应是：“骗子，我知道这意味着什么。”我的第二反应是：“快跑，拉黑他，把他的电话号码删掉。”这完全是一种过激的反应，
situation. And I think because I understand this now, I was able to apply rationality and recognize that this is a learned behavior for myself. It doesn't mean that I am not deserving of a relationship. It doesn't mean that I am somehow flawed or not healed or not working on myself. It's just something that you have to be aware of. You know, you can want a relationship and still be in the process of healing as long as you are, A, pursuing connections for the right reasons, not because of your self stigma or public stigma, and B, if you understand how, you know, your past experiences may create a pattern of behavior that is self-sabotage. But there's also this question of standards, right? because as much as we do feel the pressure to settle down from literally every direction and we want to
针对这种情况。我想，正因为我现在明白了这一点，我才能够保持理性，并认识到这是我身上的一种习得行为。这并不意味着我不配拥有恋爱关系，也不意味着我有什么瑕疵、没有治愈好或者没有在自我完善。这只是你需要意识到的一点。你知道的，你可以渴望恋爱，但只要你满足以下条件，你依然可以处于治愈的过程中：第一，你追求亲密关系是出于正确的原因，而不是因为自我污名或公众污名；第二，如果你理解过去的经历如何可能导致一种自我破坏的行为模式。但这里也存在一个关于标准的问题，对吧？因为尽管我们确实来自各个方向感受到要求稳定下来的压力，并且我们想要
experience love, being able to identify whether that person is right for you or whether you're just settling because they're the first one to come along is crucial because I truly believe it is a thousand times better being single than being in the wrong relationship. The wrong relationship can do so much harm. but deliberately choosing to build a healthy relationship with yourself or to be self-partnered, that really pays off in dividends. Being single, it can be stressful and it can be shameful at times because of what we've learnt and what we've been taught, but so can being with the wrong person or in a dysfunctional
体验爱情，但能够识别那个人是否真正适合你，还是你只是因为他是第一个出现的人而将就，这一点至关重要。因为我坚信，单身比处于错误的恋爱关系中要好上一千倍。错误的恋爱关系会造成巨大的伤害。然而，刻意选择与自己建立健康的伴侣关系，或者成为自己的伴侣，这确实会带来丰厚的回报。单身可能会带来压力，有时由于我们所学到和被教导的观念，还会伴随羞耻感，但与错误的人在一起或处于失调的
relationship. Maybe we've all heard this statistic that the happiest population group in the world is single women. But I think singleness offers so much more than just happiness. You know, a study published in the Journal of Marriage and Family, it found that single people exercise more and they are overall more physically healthy. Another study found that single people have a more diverse social circle. They are more attentive to their friends. They find that their friendships are more meaningful. And this one was really surprising, but single people also. have the lowest rates of credit card debt. Really interesting compared to married couples and couples
关系中也是如此。也许我们都听过这样一个统计数据：世界上最幸福的人群是单身女性。但我认为，单身所能带来的远不止幸福。你知道，发表在《婚姻与家庭期刊》上的一项研究发现，单身者运动更多，总体身体更健康。另一项研究发现，单身者拥有更多元化的社交圈。他们对朋友更加体贴。他们发现自己的友谊更有意义。这一点真的很让人意外，但单身者的信用卡负债率也是最低的。与已婚夫妇和
with children. And we don't hear about those benefits. All we've been told to focus on is how lonely we should feel. How happier a relationship will make us. How much stronger we will be with someone by our side. And it seems that this may actually be a bit of a fallacy. I'm going to say it one more time, no one can make you feel bad about something that you feel secure in. And if you're feeling the pressure to settle down, just remember that there is going to be a time in your life when maybe you are married or you're in a long-term relationship, you live with this person, you see them every day. Maybe you have kids and they're sticky and they cry and they turn into children or
有孩子的夫妇相比，这真的很有趣。而且我们听不到这些好处。我们被灌输的、要求我们关注的全部内容是：我们应该感到多么孤独；一段恋情会让我们变得多么幸福；有个人在身边我们会变得多么强大。而事实证明，这实际上可能是一个谬误。我要再说一遍，没有人能让你为你感到安心的事情感到难过。如果你感到了稳定下来的压力，只需记住，在你的人生中总会有这样一段时间：也许你已经结婚了，或者处于长期的恋爱关系中，你和这个人住在一起，每天都能见到对方。也许你有了孩子，他们身上黏糊糊的、会哭闹，变成了讨厌你的孩子或
teenagers who hate you and you're going to make the same, you know, tuna casserole every night. And in those moments, you are going to look back at this time in your life right now and wish that you could have just one more day of being single. One more day of being alone and getting to sleep in your own bed by yourself and only being responsible for you. And that time is right now. That time that one day you're going to look back on and be nostalgic for and wish that you were back there, that is right now. so cherish it. Additionally, when that love comes along, you will go into it so much stronger with such a better sense of yourself if you maintain your standards and you seek to elevate your life without a partner. And if that love doesn't come along, you'll feel more confident
青少年，而你每天晚上都要做同样的金枪鱼砂锅菜。在那些时刻，你将会回想起你人生中的这段时光，并希望自己能多有一天单身的时光。多一天独处、能在自己的床上独自安睡、只需对自己负责的时光。而这段时光就是现在。这段终有一天你会回味、会感到怀念并希望能回到过去的时光，就是现在，所以请珍惜它。此外，当那份爱情降临时，如果你保持了自己的标准，并在没有伴侣的情况下努力提升自己的人生，你将以更强大的姿态、带着对自我更好的认知投入其中。而如果那份爱情没有降临，你也会对自己的能力感到更加自信。
in your own abilities. You will have created a life that you love and you will be okay with whatever shame or stigma or pressure, society throws your way. As much as these social influences, both those close to us in terms of our family and our friends, but also those more macro social influences like the media, like television, try to convince us that we are only valuable if we are in a relationship, that that is like the hallmark of happiness. we all can kind of recognize that maybe that's not true, that maybe that's not something that everyone aspires for, and that a life is just as beautiful on your own. In fact, sometimes maybe even
你将创造出自己热爱的生活，并且无论社会强加给你怎样的羞耻、污名或压力，你都能泰然处之。尽管这些社会影响——既包括我们身边的家人和朋友等紧密联系，也包括媒体、电视等更宏观的社会影响——试图说服我们，只有身处恋爱关系中我们才有价值，那是幸福的标志。但我们其实都能认识到，这或许并不是真的，或许这并不是每个人都向往的，一个人生活同样可以很精彩。事实上，有时甚至
more so. And it's also a lot more beautiful than if you were to conform and settle down just because of that self and public stigma. That's an important thing to remember, especially when we do feel that implicit shame bubble to the surface and we do feel like we have to just pick someone and be with them for the rest of our life. No, no, that's totally not what we should do. We are still so young, but also life has so much more to offer than marriage and so much more to offer than partnership. And we should value that just as highly as those things. We should value the ability to adventure and explore and be alone and know ourselves just as much as we value the concept of monogamy. I hope that if you are someone who is single and maybe you're feeling a little bit down about it,
更加精彩。而且，它比你仅仅因为自我污名和公众污名而顺从并稳定下来要美好得多。这是需要记住的重要一点，尤其是当我们内心隐秘的羞耻感涌上心头，觉得必须随便挑个人并在余生中与他们在一起时。不，不，我们绝对不应该这样做。我们还那么年轻，而且生活除了婚姻还有更多丰富的内容，除了伴侣关系还有更广阔的天地。我们应该像看重那些东西一样，同等高度地重视这一点。我们应该珍视冒险、探索、独处以及了解自我的能力，其珍视程度不亚于我们对一夫一妻制概念的看重。我希望，如果你是个单身人士，并且可能为此感到有些失落，
maybe you're feeling like somehow you are less than, that there's something wrong with you, that this kind of helps you out. I hope you understand better now why it is you feel that way. It's not your fault. It's not because you are innately flawed. it's because of this huge, massive construction around the idea of singleness and also the idea of partnership. It was so important to me to do this episode. I think it's something that I personally have been thinking about a lot because of like the context and kind of my social relationships.
可能觉得自己低人一等、身上有什么毛病，这段话能对你有所帮助。我希望你现在能更好地理解为什么自己会有这种感觉。这不是你的错。这不是因为你天生有缺陷，而是因为围绕单身理念以及伴侣理念有着如此庞大、巨大的社会建构。做这一期节目对我来说非常重要。我认为这是我个人由于所处环境和社交关系一直在思考的一个问题。
So I hope you found it just as valuable as I did. I hope it helped you out. As always, if there is someone in your life who needs to hear this episode who may be going through a bit of something. stigma or shame at the moment, please do feel free to share it along. Get them to listen. Also, if you feel called to do so, please feel free to leave a five-star review wherever you are listening right now. I read every single one of them. They really make my day. Also, also, oh my God, so many alsos. I have a Patreon coming out in two weeks. I'm going to talk about it more on next week's episode. But keep your eye out. So many of you have been asking of ways that you can support
所以我希望你觉得它和我觉得的一样有价值。希望它对你有所帮助。和往常一样，如果你生命中有谁需要听到这期节目，谁目前可能正在经历一些污名或羞耻感，请务必分享给他们。让他们来听听。另外，如果你觉得有此意愿的话，请随时在你目前收听的平台上留下五星好评。我每一条都会看。它们真的能让我一整天都有好心情。还有，还有，哦天哪，有这么多的“还有”。我将在两周后推出Patreon。我会在下周的节目中对此进行更多讨论。但请大家拭目以待。你们中有那么多人一直在寻找支持我的方式，
me that is so, like, beautiful and meaningful and I'm so grateful that you guys value what I'm doing. So keep your ears out and follow me on Instagram at that psychology podcast to be the first to know when things like that happen. Or if you want to suggest a topic, if there's something you're going through and you want to hear some of the psychology behind it, Follow me over there and shoot me a message. I love hearing from you guys. As always, we will be back next week with another episode. And remember, being single is not a crime. You are going to be okay. I will talk to you soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere. but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
这真的是太美妙、太有意义了，我非常感激你们能认可我所做的事情。所以请密切关注，并在Instagram上关注我 @thatpsychology podcast，以便第一时间了解此类事情的动态。或者如果你想建议一个话题，如果你正经历着什么事情并想听听背后的心理学知识，过去关注我并给我发信息吧。我喜欢听你们分享。像往常一样，我们下周会带着另一期节目回归。记住，单身不是一种罪。你会好起来的。我们很快再聊。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人Kear Games主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全地展开的坦诚对话。但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着铠甲，
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
它向世界释放出信号：你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，你就必须去使用它。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是Michael Easter。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hand. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》，即TWO percent，在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约过后，她们决定亲自采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们常说：相信你的女朋友们。收听《The Girlfriends》，
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。《Look Back at it》播客节目中。1979年，对那时的我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是Sam J，我是Alex English。
Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
每一集，我们都会挑选你，回顾所发生的事情，并试着与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起，弄清楚我们是如何挺过那段时光的。比如Mark Lamont Hill聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客上收听《Look Back at It》，
or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或在你获取播客的任何地方。这是一档IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。